bon paris est une ville lumière est
pourtant l'un de ces monuments les plus
visités sous terre il s'agit des
catacombes qui vont fermer d'ailleurs à
partir de samedi prochain pour 6 mois de
travaux cas ils ont été endommagés par
les émanations de gaz carbonique que
nous émettons en respirant tout
simplement que crespo claude barny
enquête
un des six millions de locataires
advitam eternam du plus insolite des
sites touristiques de la capitale
jadis carrière de calcaire les
catacombes de vienne au 18e siècle cet
immense ossuaire qui recueillit les
restes de tous les cimetières parisiens
très vite cet empire de la mort connaît
un énorme succès de visite
paradoxalement à l'origine de ces
travaux explications beaucoup de
nécrophilie noctambules venait ici en
quête de sensations fortes ou d'un crâne
ou d'un tibia et pour endiguer ces
dégradations
toutes les issues à l'extérieur ont été
murées conséquence à dieu et qui lit
naturel
bonjour l'humidité avec des taux à 95%
et surtout apparition de moisissures
d'où un traitement ostéopathique en
quelque sorte qui durera six mois
l'air sera récupéré en surface l'été il
sera refroidie et ventilés dans les
galeries l'hiver il sera réchauffée et
ventilés dans les galeries le tout est
géré par une gestion technique
centralisée informatisé qui permettra de
vérifier que cette hygrométrie cette
température sont toujours constante
donc c'est un circuit qui va s'auto
réguler naturellement un peu moins de 6
millions de francs pour rendre cette
promenade un peu spéciale à quelques 170
mille visiteurs annuels
on pourrait être un peu choqués par ces
entassement funéraire non dénué
d'ailleurs d'une certaine beauté et
comment savoir si on est tombé sur de
bons voisins
aucune réponse tous ces défunts sont
anonymes aujourd'hui la mort est devenue
extrêmement discrète et donc je crois
qu'à la fin dans ces régimes ont été
beaucoup moins gênés par cette proximité
sans irrespect d'ailleurs avec même une
sorte d'affection avec ses ossements
post scriptum pour les futurs visiteurs
claustrophobes attention nous sommes à
moins 20 mètres il facétieux bien lire
cet avis des fois que vous croyez être
dans le métro il est levé